fight against climate change u.s
greenhouse gas emissions which are
helping warm the planet came roaring
back in 2021. the new data shows they
rose 6.2 percent as the economy
rebounded after the pandemic lockdowns
fueled by a
fueled rather by a rise in coal
generated power and pollution from
trucking former vice president that's al
gore welcomed us to his tennessee farm
he's been warning about the climate
emergency for decades this is a passion
of his you might expect him to be
discouraged about the world's lack of
significant action on climate change but
in a wide-ranging interview ben tracy
found he's actually quite hopeful
how big is the farm
this farm is 400 acres okay
you got a lot of land
former vice president al gore took us
for a ride in his electric atv
those are mulberry trees to show us his
farm where he's been living since the
pandemic hit i bet most people don't
think of you as farmer owl no
i don't think so
and truth to tell i don't have many
calluses on my hands
his team handles most of the farm work
tending to the sheep
and raising the animals that help
fertilize the land
where they're growing everything from
carrots and beets
to a variety of greens all sent to local
markets but this land outside nashville
is also gore's climate change laboratory
and then just push it in
he's collecting a soil sample
as he experiments with what's known as
regenerative farming that means cut back
on the on the plowing there are better
ways to plant there's actually three
times more carbon stored in the topsoil
of the earth than all the trees and
plants combined by plowing less and
making that soil more fertile scientists
say farmers could help trap massive
amounts of additional planet-warming
carbon emissions in the ground job
number one is to stop using the sky as
an open sewer for all of this man-made
global warming pollution and that's
what's making the weather crazy and
dangerous leading to all of the
consequences that are on the tv news
almost every night now
he says mother nature is now making the
most effective argument for climate
action and he's encouraged by the rapid
growth of solar and wind power and
people buying electric vehicles in
record numbers but the planet is still
rapidly warming as we continue to pump
near record amounts of pollution into
the sky
leading scientists to declare a code red
for humanity there's all this progress
being made but is it enough a realist
will tell you look we've done some
damage some of it regrettably is not
recoverable
but
we we go from where we are you want to
avoid tipping people into despair
because some people go from denial to
despair without pausing on the
intermediate step of actually doing
something about it
it is as if we can throw
a switch
and save the future of our civilization
after attending the recent climate
conference in scotland he says 2022 is
the year world leaders need to stop
talking and actually start cutting their
greenhouse gas emissions
some of the pledges are still weak and
we need to measure what they're doing
and we need to keep an eye on them it's
amazing how precise this is gore is a
major investor in a new tech platform
called climate trace it uses satellites
sensors and artificial intelligence to
track greenhouse gas emissions around
the globe from specific power plants and
factories this is the middletown steel
works in butler county
ohio to individual cargo ships and even
forests which release all of their
stored carbon when they burn
gore believes this will be an important
tool to hold countries accountable for
their pollution what do you do with that
data
publish it
we're not the climate cops
we're maybe the neighborhood watch
but our neighborhood is the whole world
we're in constant communication with the
scientific community al gore has been
sounding the climate alarm for more than
four decades first as a young
congressman the arctic is experiencing
faster melvin
and then 15 years ago with his planetary
power point in the film an inconvenient
truth it earned him an oscar a nobel
peace prize and plenty of scorn from
climate change deniers
some people called you a kook for you
know being too far left on the
environmental stuff in a kind of
unfortunate way do you feel like what
you have been saying all along has been
validated well i certainly wish i had
been wrong and more to the point what
i've been saying is really just
channeling what the scientific community
has been saying at the top of the film
you say i've been trying to tell the
story for a long time and i feel as if
i've failed to get the message across
do you now feel like you've succeeded in
getting the message across no i have not
succeeded yet the crisis is still
getting worse faster than we're
deploying the solutions there is a
remaining question about whether we will
solve it in time
[Music]
he's still optimistic mainly because of
young people all over the world now
demanding change
a lot of those young people seem pretty
fed up with politicians yeah blah blah
blah as greta says exactly
i'm with her we're sick and tired of it
and we're gonna make the change greta
tunberg and her fellow climate activists
accuse world leaders of not doing nearly
enough
and this former politician doesn't want
them to tone down their criticism i want
them to in the words of spinal tap i
want them to turn it up to an eleven
feet to the fire
absolutely and the more they can march
the more noise they can make the more
demands they insist upon the the faster
progress we'll make i'm a firm believer
in that
i call this a farmer-led movement and he
still believes the climate crisis we
created is one we can also solve
the direction of travel is clear and i
do believe that we will get there
for cbs morning's ben tracy carthage
tennessee
boy thank you mr al gore it makes me
want to go back guys and look at
inconvenient truth again because when i
first thought i was kind of like yeah
okay but now yeah i was i actually was
but now i think
i'll see it with different eyes and the
fact that he is still speaking about it
all these years later yeah and then
really mostly everything that he says
makes sense and has been true
good to see him
this way yeah and what he said in
response to what he does with the
findings he said we're not climate cops
maybe neighborhood watch for the world
yeah we all feel like that you don't
need to have a badge and walk around and
say i'm cleaning up the litter on the
ground but if we feel like we're the
neighborhood watch for this world that
we live in we can make it a better place
we don't talk about it we don't get into
it nearly enough he the way he
communicates is really evocative calling
this guy an open sewer gets to the point
pretty quickly yeah how about the line
code red for humanity we all need to pay
attention and we still have a chance to
fix it nice job ben tracy